building
robots
puts a mirror to us humans
it makes us like wonder about like what
is intelligence what is consciousness
and what is actually valuable about
human beings when when a ai system
learns to play chess better than humans
you start to let go of this idea that
humans are special because of
intelligence
it's it's something else um
maybe the flame of human consciousness
it's the capacity to uh
to feel deeply to sort of
to both suffer and to love all those
things and that somehow ai to me said
puts a mirror to that you mentioned uh
hal 9000 you have to bring it up with
the
with with these swarm bots uh crawling
on the surface of your uh cocoon in
space right
i mean
all right let me uh steel man the uh
the hell 9000 perspective okay
the poor guy just wanted to maintain the
mission and the astronauts were i mean
and i don't know if people often talk
about that but you know um
like doctors have to make difficult
decisions too when there's limited
resources you actually do have to
sacrifice human life often because you
have to make
decisions right
and i think hal was probably making that
kind of decision uh about what
what's more important the lives of
individual astronauts or the mission the
mission and i feel like ai's when other
humans
will need to make
these decisions
and it also feels like ai systems will
need to
help
make those decisions
i don't know um i guess
my question is about greater and greater
collective intelligence by systems
um
do you worry about that
uh what is the right way to sort of
solve this problem keeping a human in
the loop do you think about this kind of
stuff or are they sufficiently dumb now
the robots that that's not yet on the
horizon to think about i think it should
be on the horizon it's always good to
think about these things early because
we make a lot of technical design
decisions at this phase working with
swarm robots that it would be better to
have thought about some of these
questions early in the life cycle of a
project
there is a real interest in nasa right
now thinking about the future of human
robot interaction hri and what is the
right synergy in terms of level of
control for the human
versus level of dependence or control
for the robot and we're beginning to
test out
more of these scenarios for example the
gateway space station which is meant to
be in orbit around the moon as a staging
base for the surface operations is meant
to be able to function autonomously with
no humans in it for months at a time
because they think it's going to be
seasonal they think we might not be
constantly staffing it so this would be
a really great test of i don't know that
anybody's yet worried about hal 9000
evolving but certainly just the
robustness of some of these ai systems
that might be asked to autonomously
maintain the station while the humans
are away
or detection algorithms that are going
to say you know if you had a human pilot
they might see debris in orbit and steer
around it there'll be a lot of
autonomous navigation that has to happen
that'll be one of the early test beds
where we'll start to get a little bit
closer to that future
well the hri component is really
interesting to me
um
especially when the i includes like
almost
friendship because
like people don't realize this i think
that we you know we humans long for
connection and when you have even a
basic interaction that's just like
supposed to be just like serving you or
something
you still project it's still um
still a source of uh
meaning and connection
and so you do have to think about that i
mean hell 9000
you know the movie maybe doesn't portray
it that way but i'm sure there's a
relationship there between the
astronauts and and the robot yeah
especially when you have greater and
greater level of intelligence and maybe
that addresses the
the happiness question too
yeah i think there's a there's a great
book by kate darling who's one of my
she's colleagues
yeah she's amazing we've been she's
already been on this podcast
but we talk all the time and we're we're
supposed to talk
and we've been missing each other and
we're gonna make it happen soon yeah
come come down to texas okay all right
anyway yeah she's amazing she has this
book it's just her whole work is about
this connection with robots yeah this
beautiful connection that we have with
robots but i think it's greater and
greater importance when it's out in
space because it could help alleviate
some of the loneliness right one of the
projects in the book that i gave you
which is a catalog of the projects that
we've worked on over the last five years
is this social robot that was developed
at the media lab and we one of the first
years in 2017 that we flew a zerg flight
we took the social robot along and tried
to do a little bit of a very scaled down
human study to look at these questions
because you do imagine that we would
form a bond a real bond with the social
robots that might be
not just serving us on a mission but
really be our teammates on a future
mission and i do think that that could
have a powerful role in the mental
health and just the stability of a crew
is to have some other robot friends come
along
you